hello everybody my name is markiplier
I'm here joined by Kevin the editor of
the game grumps he heard that I had this
non name-brand alcohol and he just had
to join me for it cuz he loved the stuff
he was sick I told them that you were
sick and you were drinking this a while
ago yeah yeah apparently it does it also
helps with making this game easier to
play so Cheers
give you more than me oh god that's good
but when I'm on my fifth one so it gets
a little less good with each one you do
too even okay Kevin edit yourself out
editing myself out yeah we're gonna
still see you yeah those are cord there
don't knock over any [ __ ] okay bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye okay so it's
officially the start of the episode now
I forgot what I was doing oh yeah
because I just I just beat chica so I
just be cheated so that means that I got
chicas ultimate skill which means the
ultimate skill for chicken but I don't
know what that does so hopeful why and
why is oh that's what that meter was I
was wondering what that meter was it was
a green meter that filled up every time
I was in a battle but it would never get
full because it would need to like last
the entire time of the battle I don't
know what that means but I'm guessing if
I guard a lot for that particular
character that might mean that I could
do what I need to do so but before I do
that I'm assuming that I can go fight
Bonnie now cuz Bonnie's probably back in
the room where I first got Bonnie
because I haven't visited any of these
rooms again but yeah there is Otto
Bonnie and the bottom left over there
Todd that is creepy as hell we're done
man because I'm about to smack him into
another oblivion in Glu ugly
oh no you're so creepy oh no toy Bonnie
just the worst I've ever seen in my life
okay so I'll be right back I'm gonna
murder this guy murderer hard murderer
me luck Haley no and I'm not gonna be
back because I want you to see it in
full effect of me murdering him okay so
I don't know like is it like damage
that's taken that causes Oh God
oh god I'm not doing anything to Bonnie
oh oh why why here and ate David's one
run away oh crap y'all having a guard
that's what I'm gonna do
guard up all right hot star God uh-huh
the guard it did nothing I'm just gonna
be I'm gonna be dead so let's just get
through it as quickly as possible yep
there goes boxy oh boy how do things
making anyone to beat these bastards I
got like the best [ __ ] how am I supposed
to do this it doesn't make any sense
even if I get the best equipment I'm not
gonna be able to beat anybody good god I
just I don't have enough defense for
they annihilate me like two hits yep
they're going yep I'm dead okay all
right great way to sort of so thanks
Kevin we're go god damn it I just I
walked outside I told Kevin that I was
drinking fire Oh nan name-brand
cinnamon whiskey and he was like haha -
so all right whatever
oh man it was a fun day for me this is a
fun day
okay so I need another plan because
obviously these guys are really tough to
beat
I imagine like I would have imagined
they would have been all done on the
same difficulty level but apparently
that is not the case so toy or mangles
probably over in Fox's area but I
definitely don't know I mess with fat
with mangle because Lee Boggs is like
homeless my toughest character besides
Bonnie of course he was really really
tough
so what I gotta do what I probably got
to do and what I probably should have
been doing before is saving up tokens to
try to get the items that can fully
revived cuz if I have those then I don't
need chica to be able to add don't need
to wait to chica
because chicas turn comes after the
enemy's turned because she is slower now
if I speed everyone up she will go
faster but when someone's in danger I
need those items so when I need to do
right now is I need to farm up enough to
get items and only items I only need to
worry about items now so is gonna take a
while
I'm gonna be doing this
but hey you know what you guys are gonna
love it because we're here together I
mean that's knows more thing I'm here
with you you're here with me all having
a great time like I don't know if you
guys are playing the drinking game with
me
like I hope that someone out there waits
until the entire playlist is done the
entire series is out there in the open
and you you play this game with me it is
a fun game to play like I will be
perfect I'm on my fifth shot right now
but frankly I don't feel it all that
much except I feel just a slight sense
of giddiness overall and jacksepticeye
is rubbed off on me all of his Irish
tolerance for alcohol is finally caught
up with me I'm doing real good here but
now like seriously that's what I'm
talking about in the last episode like
the sheer fact of making videos should
be fun especially for youtubers like no
matter what you do what you do should be
fun it should be fulfilling and fun at
the same time and not everyone gets a
chance to do that that's why I'm so
incredibly lucky to be able to do that
with you guys to be able to just play
around and dick around all day every day
God is greatest feeling in the world I
hope you guys get to feel it someday
because I know if you pursue your dreams
like it's rough at first like when I was
first starting out on YouTube I didn't
play I had fun look I still know I don't
know I'm not even trying to get a big
county boy less me when I first heard
about doing YouTube I had the best time
in my life I had so much fun every
goddamn day was another [ __ ]
adventure like and then when drunk my
craft started up which is coming back
I'm so happy the drunk minecraft is
starting up not just cuz I get to drink
more but just because like the fact that
I got to play with my friends and
possibly not even like guaranteed but
possibly have a chance to do it for a
living and now I get to do that for a
living it's like it's like the most
amazing thing I could ever ask for it's
so cool like it's so unbelievably cool
and it's all thanks to you guys for just
being here and supporting me like I can
literally do whatever I want and it's so
it's such a privilege to be able to do
that um like I don't mean it like I'm
killing party hats in a game ball taking
shots of whiskey like please oh man now
I'm shedding a Saturday learn what days
they Thursday I don't even know like it
doesn't even matter anymore because I
have the most fun job in the world and
like when I went back to Cincinnati I
like had a realization that you know it
doesn't have to be so asinine about it
doesn't have to be just like a 9 to 5
grind every day you know what I mean
like I have the best time of my life
just entertaining you guys because
that's what I love to do it is so fun
every part of it I wouldn't I wouldn't
trade it for a single thing in the
entire world I wouldn't not I wasn't
paying attention they're just that body
lock up and die there but just like
thank you guys like that's why I say
thank you because like it's hard to
describe what you guys have allowed me
to do with my life
the fact that like from the start of
what I was doing to now I'm able to just
have the best time of anything I've ever
done in my life I'm just able to have
the best time every single day and like
I'm a gripe and groan about certain
games it's whatnot but that doesn't mean
that I'm ever ever ungrateful for the
opportunities that I've been given
anyway I'll stop rambling about that
I'll get back to five nights at Freddy's
[ __ ] boys [ __ ] chica in the ass and
shoving soda up everywhere but good
Scott dam like at the fact that I'm able
to play a game like this this is proof
in and of itself like I didn't even I
didn't even want to play this game
originally but now I'm so happy that I
did I'm so happy that I'm doing it this
way as opposed to any other way because
god damn that's like the best time
making videos that a long time and I'm
gonna play drug my crab my best
in the world it's gonna be phenomenal oh
[ __ ] I love you guys anyway enough
batting around I'm not drunk yet
probably I'm but well you keep a secret
you ain't gonna telling your putting a
you couldn't tell nobody
all right whatever I blame it all on
Kevin Kevin did it
Kevin how dare you okay so what am i
doing I have no idea I've got a god oh
that's right I was trying to build up
for the full extra large pizza items and
I don't think I need extra large sodas
but I do need that just in case like
last minute I need to heal I got a heal
there's no other way about it I got a
heal so I can't have anything
interrupting that if I want to survive
against that goddamn camera how am I
gonna go he gets come get up I'm gonna
go against camera next because what am i
doing no I was so far me I'm not done
for me no ate [ __ ] I get to puppet okay
on I gotta get to the puppet everybody
you stupid hats why am i fighting party
outside they need to think about that
like why am i fighting party at Swire
party hats look the enemy in this game
we've all the things that can possibly
be the enemy why party acts like what
didn't even make any sense
like I guess there wouldn't be any other
enemy though could you possibly be an
enemy I guess to make sense whatever
this game doesn't make a goddamn bacin
when I was when I was first anticipating
this game I was anticipating there was
gonna be more about like Freddy it was
gonna be less about the combat in this
game has been a lot about the combat
like actual fighting fighting which has
been really weird for me because I don't
usually play games like this but it's
like I thought it was gonna be so much
more in the way of just random ass
[ __ ] that Freddy as Freddy [ __ ] boy
it was gonna be doing and yet here we
are just like I'm legitimately grind
against party ads I'm happy fun what is
life what is my life I have a great life
I am so happy oh [ __ ] okay
she's elite health that's good okay so
I'm going to attempt to fight the camera
now because I'm pretty sure that's the
only thing that I might be able to beat
and I will be able to beat it because I
will actually be able to heal what I
need to heal
engage the camera mother yes engage that
camera grandpa do all right come on this
is it this is the big one
this is the big all ultimate boob doober
uber be booper dooper okay so um I
really should use like my skills that
actually do good stuff and actually
cause havoc and pain cuz if I could get
them stunned that mean great
I always paralyze that's phenomenal what
happened I've been doing that that's
like a great thing that I could be
possibly doing I'm such a [ __ ] idiot
like I I love RPGs like don't get me
wrong I really actually do love RPGs
because they're phenomenal games I used
to play like found bands is seven eight
nine ten all like long periods of times
Hey
like recently I have not played any
mostly because like I haven't really
found RPGs that I like besides like
Dragon Age and stuff like that but I
don't know yes I don't know I don't know
I'm tired but I'll be right back I feel
having I'm done talking for now hey holy
crap why haven't I been in paralyzing
people before why haven't I been
poisoning people before I'm such a
dingleberry hey [ __ ] did it
eat my [ __ ] you camera brick oh well
then I think the door has been open for
me I bet there's some like there's a
different ending for uh for uh going in
there before I beat all the dudes so I'm
gonna save a separate save and I'm gonna
go face Mike Schmidt so Mikey
whoa hey you [ __ ] was that Russian you
were speaking you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
didn't invite me to you not a b-bow
Chewie I'm gonna get your dicks now this
is more like it
this is what I was expecting when I was
over you five nights at [ __ ] boys oh no
I'm not ready for this oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] I wasn't ready God dog I'm
bugged I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ]
Oh Diddy [ __ ] goddamnit okay ah let's
try something I don't know he's gonna
work forget we're not da were [ __ ] oh
that's not fair why can you eat a pizza
oh why does a large pizza do five oh my
goodness is so bad if I can't level up
anymore like what it is folks to do this
cave is gonna be so hard
all right just kill me and get it over
with kill me kill me kill me kill me
kill please please end my torment and my
pain all right so all right I'm dead
okay so obviously that ain't Mike
Schmidt that ain't [ __ ] Mike Schmidt
by goddamn mile so somehow what I got to
do somehow what I got to do is I got to
get all the things necessary to be able
to do but I need to do and for some
[ __ ] reason like I got a I don't know
what I get I think what I actually got
to do is I got a farm up to the point
where I have like all the kingly weapons
from all the different hats that are
around because I've gotten the hats from
like the level two enemies in the level
three enemy in the other room the Omega
and so what I need to do is I need to
farm
the original guys until I get to the
point where I'm able to do what I need
to do
god it's like damn this is [ __ ] hard
like okay so what's gonna happen is I'm
gonna be farming for a while but frankly
I don't want to cut away because I'm
having a good time talking to you guys
cuz I haven't been able to do that so
with what's on Liam I think I got a barn
these original party hats until I get
I bet this first one is gonna be
Freddy's microphone like the kingly
microphone because Freddy was the
character that I had first and I was
alone when I had Freddy so and these
were the only things that I had when I
had Freddy and I lost oh man I lost yet
so badly you like right off the bat but
I'm willing to bet that somewhere if I
fight these guys enough I will get a
kingly microphone out of that and I
think that'll help me greatly when I
play this goddamn game and I'll actually
be able to beat the things that I need
to beat but not yet because I'm willing
to bet that I need to do everything that
I need to do but anyway one of the
things can I talk about like it's hard
to come up with things to talk about
when I don't have any like feedback from
you guys later oh yeah you saw that
thing you saw that movie great I'm so
glad you did all right cool how's your
day great me too all right cool but I
mean I guess among the many things that
I could talk about is like
I always talk about like my experiences
in life and what it took me to get where
I am today and how I aspire to be good
and I don't know why I'm talking like an
Irish pirate butter it's just going to
be a good time but like I don't know
it's it's it's an interesting thing
being a youtuber in life having that be
permanently engrained in what I am and
how I do things
but I mean I guess one things I could
talk about that you know I I don't often
talk about is like what the
repercussions of being a youtuber are
and and what are the downsides because I
always talk about the upsides but there
often are downsides that you know it's
it's got to be a parent for everyone
that wants to be you to the reports it
seems extremely appealing in it is like
I wouldn't trade this job for the world
it's fantastic but like people need to
be aware that when you're trying to be
youtuber
it's really really really difficult to
do I don't want to discourage people of
doing it because that would be
irresponsible of me to say don't pursue
your dream because I want you to pursue
your dreams recklessly and with reckless
abandon whatever you want to do but
frankly like being a youtuber it's it's
a risky risky bet to place on yourself
like if you got the perseverance to do
like I guarantee anyone could do that
they have to believe and the like the
willpower to conquer what they want to
conquer both in themselves and in you
know the environment that they're in
which is YouTube but frankly even when I
started like I had doubts I doubts after
I lost my first channel like wave will
attest like after I lost my first
channel I had no idea what I was gonna
be doing III sort of had a reality check
like I'm not making money there's no way
I can make money off of this it's just a
hobby what am i doing I got to focus on
engineering and and thankfully I talked
to waiting you know we losing I should
keep going but it's like what what else
could could I have done because I I
loved it so much it was so good to me
and it was so fantastic and opportunity
to me that I literally couldn't have
done anything else I literally could not
have stopped I guarantee you if I had
tried to stop who would not have worked
because I was so fervently believing
that it's what I wanted to do and that's
the kind of belief that you have to have
but the downside of that and that's very
inspirational for me to say to you guys
in this very inspirational for me to
tell you guys that I conquered my baser
instincts and I pursued it but frankly
99% of the people that try YouTube will
unfortunately not get anywhere
maybe not 99% maybe like 95% or 90%
it's like it's so hard these things and
I feel bad because there's so much
competition out there and there's so
much skill there's so much skill and
talent that is there but it's not seen
because it's overshadowed by everyone
attempting and that's not to say like
people shouldn't try as much as they are
like everyone should try if they want
driving it's just so hard for people I
feel that if I had to start over again
now
today I don't know if I'd ever be able
to do it look I don't know if I would
have the willpower or the strength to be
able to do what I needed to do and I
wanted to do like I really don't know if
I could because because of the way
YouTube is set up now and it's so hard
to get noticed among to see people that
are trying to get noticed and everyone
wants to get famous just for the sake of
being famous and it's like what what
what is the point
oh I did find a kingly microphone I
didn't even know I found a king of the
microphone I was talking there but it's
like some people may say what I didn't
mean say what's this point I meant say
some people may say what's the point
because it's so hard to get noticed and
then even if you do get noticed like the
chance of getting to the point where
you're able to make a sustainable living
is even rarer after that like it's it's
even rarer and especially in terms of
like just doing Let's Plays it's not as
fulfilling as doing any other thing like
it's it's good and I'm glad to do it I'm
happy to do it I'm happy that you like
my videos but like Let's Plays
themselves are not all that innovative I
mean I may be able to put my clever spin
up fix by drinking booze and playing a
stupid game that's great and fun and I
may have a great time with it but it's
like I still respect so much the people
that can do the amazing things I'm using
special affects the actual comedy that
comes with things as like I want to do
those so badly and I'm able to have the
opportunity don't get me wrong I do but
it's like it's like I what is it like
I'm having trouble finding the right
words but it's it's just it's so
unfortunate that that is the determining
factor luck it's so unfortunate it's odd
because it plays into what I was doing
in five nights at freddys in beating
2020 modes on them it's so based on luck
and luck is so unfair but the thing
about luck is the more you persevere
against luck eventually in
give way please us have to be so
unwaveringly adamant and so unwaveringly
sure that what you're doing is what you
want to do and if you can conquer that
then by God you can do pretty much
anything I mean that doesn't that
doesn't apply disease YouTube that
applies to anything at all I mean this
drunk advice from markiplier so I take
this with a grain of salt but it's like
you can do whatever you want but it's
the the difference between the people
that want to do it and the people that
do it aren't just they do it they do it
more they do it harder they do it better
in that sounds like sexual innuendos
from a drunk [ __ ] but they just do
they do hard and fast and as good as
they can and at the end of the day they
may fail over and over and over and over
but the end of the day you're still
trying no matter how many times they
failed no matter how many times they do
they try and they better themselves then
they better themselves with each fail
they like you'll find quotes all over
the internet about how no matter how
many times you fail if so long as you
get back up you didn't fail but like
it's not just about that you have to you
have to have the idea that you need to
do that but also you need to have the
the the perspective to realize what went
wrong before and adapt accordingly to
change to be better next time to
increase your odds of succeeding and
that's the hardest thing that's
something that can't be done and all
this I'm not giving you advice I don't
like to give advice I don't like to give
people advice what I'm telling you guys
is I'm trying to fill time in the pker I
try I'm farting I'm trying to fill time
but enough like I really don't like
giving advice because I feel like advice
even the best advice in the world won't
actually change you won't actually make
you do what you want to do it won't
actually make you a different or better
person what it will do is give you an
outline it'll give you an outline of
what you should do and then it's up to
you to follow it or not because advice
is
silly and people ask me for advice all
the time and I'm like the only advice I
have is that I figured everything out
like it and it's what you have to do
because you have to figure everything
out to adapt to your specific situation
because my situation was different than
yours and my situation is from my
perspective and my set of skills and my
being and my person that I am you if you
want to do anything you not only have to
learn the basic skills you not only have
to fail until you succeed you not only
have to persevere no matter what but you
have to learn the answers for yourself
there's no key to life there's no answer
guide there's no secret the secret is
are you capable of understanding what
went wrong and why it went wrong that's
the real key so anyway I've rambled
enough what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
end this episode while I'm ahead
I think I'm in good time I have no idea
it might be like I'm out whatever I'll
talk a little bit more because I can
fill any void with as much words as I
want silly this is what you expected out
of five nights of [ __ ] boys world world
shattering advice from drunk markiplier
starring [ __ ] Freddie Franz bear [ __ ]
Ducker and Bonnie the butt [ __ ]
hey gets good time over here in Freddy
[ __ ] bears pizzeria
I don't know goddamn idea what I'm
saying anymore oh I should have stuck
with the advice [ __ ] what have I been
doing with my life how do you learn what
am i doing no miss I have no idea
I wanna shot
that's what I want I'll look into the
next step sir but I can get another shot
but I gotta do a lot of grinding off
screen because I get ignite I've no idea
if I have the cupcake or not I don't if
I do I'm [ __ ] up because I've been
doing this way too long but I've been
getting a lot of tokens I will give that
I've been getting a lot of tokens
because Wade told me that I would need
to farm off-screen but frankly I don't
think I need to do that I think you guys
are off the puppet rock oh god you hated
the puppet I forgot about the puppet
[ __ ] Oh dad that would have been
terrible because I haven't saved it
forever
Jesus oh I am NOT doing okay I've exam
do it fantastic no now don't go to the
kitchen because you're freaking a jewel
okay so now that we got this now we got
this [ __ ] out of the way I think I
could finally on this episode here I
can't believe the camera is [ __ ] dead
I can why can you not anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching I am
having just a blasty blast playing this
game with you guys so you I thank you
everybody so much for watching check the
annotation for more cool videos that
I've done and if you haven't well you
probably yeah but seeing all the five
nights at Freddy's I have done the past
check it out again the animations were
cool that compilation is cyndago put
together freakin amazing
thank you guys you guys are awesome have
a good night everybody
and as always I will see you
no no no no
you go about you what